und dann beginnen wir mit der heutigen
sitzung heute kommt der erste wirklich
ganz ganz große philosoph der neuzeit
dran wir hatten der letzten sitzung
etwas uns mit dem so beschäftigt so wer
von ihnen kann auch mal kurz sagen was
das entscheidende bei uns so war mit
blick auf das gute
wobei tendenziell eher das gute
angesiedelt im vergleich etwa zu platon
mir ganz schematischen
dann legen sie noch bei platon war es so
bei platon hatten wir oben und unten zur
die natur
das sind die gegenstände stände oder
auch die physis es ist es was verrät und
entsteht
wir müssen hier aufsteigen hier ist idee
dass es gut ist noch irgendwie über den
ideen wie genau das zu verstehen ist das
haben wir uns lange gefragt was heißt es
dass das gute die das guten jenseits des
seins ist über den ideen steht das ist
eine spannende frage
wir hatten jedenfalls gesehen dass es
hier so eine art graduelle das
verhältnis also hier unten ist irgendwie
0 und die weiter wie hier runter kommen
zu der natur oder zu den schatten
bildern desto weniger sein ist der hat
einen komparativen wickel von sein es
gibt etwas was mir weniger scientist das
ist uns heute ein bisschen fremd heute
sagt man entweder etwas ist oder es
nicht aber nichts ist mehr oder weniger
scheint etwas kann mehr oder weniger
groß oder klein oder teuer oder was auch
immer sein aber nicht sein
sein ist nichts was ich gratulieren also
ja graduell wachsen lässt das geht nicht
bleibt heutzutage ist denkt man in den
meisten fällen so blatter denkt das
anders sagt gibt ein voll sind von sein
das sind die ideen die ideen von
natürlichen entitäten es gibt eine
riesen diskussion bei platon drüber von
was es alles ideen geben kann
kann es zb den von bäumen geben kann es
ideen von zahlen geben platten hat meine
idee häufig eine zahl im kopf also die
idee der 5 die idee der zahl vier idee
wie sieht es aber aus mit solchen dingen
wie hässlichen dingen oder der
alltäglichen dingen gibt es die idee der
zahnbürste gibt es die idee eine
zigarettenkippe oder so war es nun also
sie sehen da wird es schon sehr
schwierig jedenfalls ist es ein
gradueller begriff des 1 und mit diesem
seien hängt eben ganz eng
das gut zusammen sein und gut sind bei
ihm sehr eng verbunden
und wir hatten dann gesehen ich
wiederhole mal kurz bei bei kloten ist
es so dass hier dann noch das eine mit
hinzu kommt dass eine
das gute und das eine und die stehen
auch über dem sein sohn sich das war
auch für uns ein bisschen kontur tief
durch eine und das gute stück über dem
sein sind noch mehr einheitlicher das
gute und das seien und dass das eine das
sagt der begriff das ist halt das eine
ist das absolut oder ihr so wie auch
immer und das gute ist halt so haben wir
jetzt interpretiert das was vorzuziehen
ist dasjenige was normativität enthält
das was auch immer in die besser ist das
was bevor zu bevorzugen ist so könnte
man sagen das wäre auch ein kunde sein
die erste stelle zwischen denen und wir
hatten dann gesehen in dieser linie
weiterführen thomas von aquin sagt dass
gute hält mit der science fülle zusammen
und designs fülle
da sieht man wieder dass es natürlich so
ein komparative begriff von sein designs
für das heißt es sein kann mehr oder
weniger gefüllt sein
50 prozent sein oder 102 11 will das
gute wird an der science für bemessen
dann stellt sich bei uns aber wenn man
die frage ja wie sieht es dann
bitteschön mit schlechten re büssen
handlungen aus existieren überhaupt oder
müssten die nicht irgendwie hier zu
finden seine nullpunkt und das führt
dann zu dir etwas paradoxen these dass
es keine schlechten handlungen gibt das
war so eine frage thomas von aquin
aufgeworfen hat gibt es nur als auch
ökologisch science mäßig gibt es nur
gute handlung und schlechte handlungen
sind dann hier 0
aber wir sind ja gar nicht sehen dass
das problem
dieser platonischen tradition dann gibt
es eine andere tradition die sich nach
beratung in eine andere richtung bewegt
das ist die aristotelische dimension
aristotelische tradition da geht es dann
ihr um die glückseligkeit glückseligkeit
dies nicht unbedingt im sinne von nur
lust und so was seine zufriedenheit
zufriedenheit und gedacht als endpunkt
eines ziels eines strebens das gute ist
das was das leben erfüllt teleologische
wir haben gesehen platon holt das gute
wieder irgendwie so ein bisschen in die
welt der sinnlichen dinge hallo wir
haben es wieder hinbekommen aber ab und
zu ist der beamer nicht an machbar dann
muss immer ein student aufstiegsanlagen
wohlig in lausanne
zurückdrehen ok alles klar
also es gibt dann diese tendenz auf das
streben also die strebens tendenz deren
erfüllung das gute ist das ist so diese
aristotelische tradition die das gute
dann auch ihr so hier in diesem bereich
hier verortet weil physis hat ein teller
scanners ist das streben die natur ist
es dass veränderliche das hat auch ein
streben in sicht das hat ziele
alles strebt nach etwas für alles was da
strebt in der natur gibt es allen gut
also wenn man jetzt das gute vom streben
her des individuums her betrachtet dann
kommt das gut so ein bisschen hier
wieder in dem die welt hinein
da ist sie nicht mehr das ist das gute
nicht mehr über allem so als es das ist
man könnte sagen gerade hat er sein
liberales totales hat ihr ein
lebensweltlichen begriff des guten
so könnte man das fassen
ja gesagt das gut wird auch in
verschiedenen hinsichten ausgesagt also
wie sein man kann es analog sehen oder
man kann es nie weg wie vox sehen es
gibt verschiedene bereiche verschiedene
hinsichten den guten verschiedene
bedeutungen hat ähnlich wie bei dem sein
auch aber entscheiden ist bares tod
lässt dass es in die welt wieder hinein
nimmt und an das streben bindet und
jetzt ist barroso ein anderer fall wie
mir scheint bei wieso ist es so er sagt
also die vernunft die bei platon ja auch
eher mit den ideen hier zusammenhängt
die vernunft die vernunft war hier unten
ist dann nach platon als systemisches
technologie der psychologie die
erkenntnistheorie und das ist er so die
ontologie und die dinge die es gibt es
gibt ideen die idee das gut dass die
gegenstelle natur und allen bereichen
des seins wird ein
erkenntnistheoretische einstellung eine
kenntnis theoretisch vermögen zugeordnet
die ideen werden von der vernunft
erkannt geschaut genauer gesagt und die
gegenstände in der natur
der fuß ist die veränderlichen dinge
dies setzt plattform gleich mit großem
glauben mit dem bloßen meinen
also mit dem vermuten und das werden sie
sicherlich auch so sehen dass vermuten
etwas anderes ist als vernünftig
erkennen vernünftig erkennen ist gewiss
absolut das vermuten hier unten vermuten
meinen das ist ein bisschen unsicher das
ist auch wahrscheinlichkeit beziehung es
ist recht wahrscheinlich aber
hundertprozentig sicher bin ich mich und
ich habe es auch nicht ganz klar vor
augen
also dieser diesem bereich hier unten
dem ordnet platon hier ihr system ist
nicht ganz so sichere vermögen zu und
jetzt haben wir gesehen barroso ist es
ganz anders er dreht das ganze irgendwie
stellt das auf dem kopf euro so ist es
so er sagt die vernunft hier geht es
nicht nur die garantie für das gute und
das ist eine ganz moderne wendung
sondern die vernunft kann auch ein grund
für das böse sein
und daraus folgt unserem umkehrschluss
wenn die vernunft nicht mehr unbedingt
jetzt die garanten für das gute ist
könnte da nicht doch das gute er hier
liegen in dieser natur die jetzt
unabhängig von der vernunft ist und das
ist so grobe these barroso er sagt der
vernunft zustand er denkt das ganze auch
jetzt plötzlich geschichtlich das ist
auch eine neuerung in der debatte um
gute böse bedenkt dass gute
geschichtlich er sagt es gibt phasen
innerhalb der entwicklung der
menschlichen kultur in denen das die
menschliche geschichte gut war oder wo
die menschliche entwicklung der
menschlichen zustand gut war und es gibt
eine phase oder eine epoche den zustand
der nicht gut ist oder wo das böse in
die welt kommen
im grunde genommen gibt es diese tendenz
schon im sündenfall der geschichte des
sündenfalls in der bibel auch da wird
unterschieden zwischen verschiedenen
epochen eine woche war tendenziell eher
gut
und dann gibt es die woche nach dem
sündenfall nacht in essen vom baum der
erkenntnis die tendenziell eher böse
sind
das ist ein geschichtliches modell und
wo sieht das ganze sieht das ganz
ähnlich obwohl er sicherlich nicht so
sehr religiös jetzt war es ganz ähnlich
sagt in diesen naturzustand deswegen
finde ich es ganz interessant hier
wieder fußes verbindung zu bringen was
bei platon ganz unten ist in diesem
naturzustand da waren wir vielleicht
eigentlich gar nicht gut oder böse das
war so ihr indifferent jedenfalls hatten
wir dort noch gewisse gefühle wie zb das
mitleid wir hatten eine sehr gesunde
selbstliebe
dies ermöglichte mit dem arm mit den
anderen gut zurechtzukommen mit den
anderen menschen und in dem die vernunft
sich entwickelte das von unvermögen kam
ganz viele probleme die welt nämlich
dasjenige dass wir uns immer verglichen
haben mit anton wir haben uns zuletzt
gemessen an den anderen
der ist reicher die ist erfolgreicher
wir haben solche kriterien der der
quantität auch angelegt wir haben das
mitleid durch vernunft überlegungen
gelernt zu unterdrücken das war ein
zitat was ich glaube ich auch eine
zusammenfassung im geschickt hatte
worauf so sagt der philosoph kann da in
seinem zimmer sitzen und unter e mail
also außerhalb des zimmers auf der
straße kann jemand irgendwie ermordet
werden und der philosoph muss ich nun
eine gute belegung zurechtlegen die gute
guten gedanken zurechtlegen so eine
vernunft überlegungen so was
vernünftiges um gründe zu finden warum
jetzt da nicht helfen müssen die
vernunft kann uns auch irgendwie
überzeugen oder überreden unmoralisch zu
sein das ist ein alltägliches phänomen
dass die das bemerkte dabei sich ein
klein dass man dann wenn man nur lange
genug nachdenkt immer irgendeinen grund
findet der dafür herhalten kann dass man
jetzt irgendwas nicht macht was man
nicht gerne machen würde obwohl es
vielleicht eigentlich gefordert wäre
moralisch und auch diese ambivalente
funktion der vernunft hebt russo ab und
er sagt dann die natürliche selbstliebe
als nur das vor französisch wird
pervertiert durch die vernunft seiner
eigenen liebe hamburg kennen sie also
das ist das eigentum und solche dinge
die dann wird sich ganz wichtig werden
also die vernunft ist nicht mehr nur gut
sein die vernunft hat eine schattenseite
die vernunft bringt jetzt endlich auch
das böse in die welt und das steht etwas
der platonischen tradition entgegen
dann hatten wir noch ein denker vor muss
so behandelt dass war leibnitz leibnitz
hat das böse oder das gute wir reden ja
vor allem von guten in einer ganz
interessanten theorie gefassten eine
metaphysik in einer theorie der besten
aller möglichen welten
auch hier könnte man sagen ist das gut
bei leibnitz er so ein komparative oder
vielleicht ein superlativ begriff die
beste aller möglichen welten da spricht
nicht so sehr vom guten sondern vom
besten
aber das beste beinhaltet ja auch es
ginge auch gut aber nicht ganz so gut
das beste ist die letzte steigerungsform
des guten
es gibt sicherlich eine welt die ist
auch gut aber es wäre eben nicht die
beste aller möglichen welten und wir
haben gesehen dass der begriff des guten
bei leibnitz ganz stark auf den
gottesbegriff bezogen ist der aber nicht
homogen ist der in sich die
unterscheidung von wille und verstand
hat und wir hatten das so und so
dargestellt dass wille und verstand
jetzt endlich sich arrangieren müssen
und dann am ende zu der wahl der besten
aller möglichen welten kommen diese art
kompromiss ist aber jetzt kein
schlechter kompromiss sei ein sehr
einleuchtende kompromiss der wille will
immer unmittelbar das gute und die
vernunft der verstand gottes ist
gebunden an die möglichkeit der
schöpfung ausmalung metaphysik und aus
diesen zwei anforderungen des auf das
unmittelbare gute gehen wollen des
willens und die vorgaben des verstandes
das eben die schöpfung endlich sein muss
folgt dann in art einer kalkulation
die beste aller möglichen welten beiden
ansprüchen genüge tut
das ist sozusagen das gute bei leibnitz
und von dieser metaphysische spekulation
bei leibnitz kommen wir jetzt in der
heutigen sitzung zurück nicht nur auf
die welt nicht nur auf also nicht auf
die ideen auch nicht auf die gegenstände
in der welt auf das streben der
aristoteles gibt es dennoch die
glückseligkeit seligkeit almunia oder
monja bekommen jetzt bei kant
letztendlich ganz auf den punkt wir
kommen bei kannten mich jetzt auf den
menschen auf den einzelnen menschen mehr
noch wir kommen nicht nur auf seine
handlung wie bei thomas von aquin sollen
wir kommen auf seinen willen wir
dringend als ins innerste des menschen
vor in seine psyche kann sagt das gute
und das böse die finden sich eigentlich
um aller innersten des menschen nicht
irgendwann ideen die das umschwirren
auch nicht in der niederen natur sich im
geschichtlichen epochen sollen die
finden sich im innersten von uns in dem
was uns als person ausmacht nämlich in
unserem willen wollen unsere maxime wir
kommen da noch drauf das ist ein mann
erkannt dass es ein sehr realistisches
bildnis wird ja häufig sehr idealisiert
dargestellt aber wir sind ja hier
realisten und er hat gelebt im 18
jahrhundert überwiegend es 80 jahre
geworden und hat zwei werke geschrieben
die wir heute behandeln werden einmal
die grundlegung zur metaphysik der
sitten
das ist sein bekanntestes moral
philosophisches werk in den usa
liest man vor allem dieser schrift auch
im ausland vor allem die grundlegung zur
metaphysik der sitten
das ist ein sehr idealer einführungstext
das ist ein text mit dem man sich sehr
sehr gut seiner ethik panel kann weil er
sehr verständlich geschrieben ist und
nicht so viele voraussetzungen
dann gibt es noch ein zweites werk von
ihm und zwar heißt dass die kritik der
praktischen vernunft sie haben
sicherlich alle die kritik der reinen
vernunft schon mal gehört das ist sein
theoretisches hauptwerk die kritik der
praktischen ist ein praktisches
hauptwerk sein moral philosophisches
haptik also diese zweite schrift hier
die ist eigentlich viel wichtiger als
die grundlegung zur metaphysik der
sitten sie wird aber viel seltener
gelesen weil sie viel schwieriger ist
und viel systematischer alles zusammen
führt wir werden jetzt heute aus beiden
werken was lesen auszüge
wir werden aus der grundlegung zur
metaphysik der sitten sein begriff des
guten uns anschauen und aus der kritik
der praktischen vernunft die stellen
behandeln die das höchste gut
wir haben sie haben das schon mal gehört
wir haben das ab und zu schon mal zur
sprache gebracht weil nämlich bei
aristoteles ein übersetzer auch vom
höchsten gut sprach da hatte ich dann
aber gesagt das sollte man nicht als das
höchste gut übersetzen weil das höchste
gut ist und begriff den kant geprägt hat
und das hat mit aristoteles mit seiner
theorie nichts zu tun
aristo das kann man sagt das beste gut
oder so weiter aber nicht das höchste
gut und diese theorie diät nehmen wir
seine kritik der praktischen von uns
jetzt haben wir hier ein paar leitfragen
nämlich warum nach kant ein wille ein
guter wille nur absolut gut zu nennen
ist das ist eine starke these wie
verhalten sich gute handlung und guter
wille zueinander
wie muss der wille motiviert werden um
ein guter wille zu werden und was ist
nach kann das höchste gut
diese diskussion die wir heute hier
führen werden die knüpft ganz direkt an
dieses beispiel mit mutter teresa
ansehen sich an einer der ersten
sitzungen wie sieht's aus was ist jetzt
gut ist jetzt dieser eine imaginäre
mönchgut der die menschen mit
quecksilber vergiftet und liegt
natürlich obwohl eigentlich nur das gute
will
oder ist es mode ära in unserem beispiel
jetzt ins effektiven beispiel die eben
nur berühmt werden wollte aber viel gute
handlungen getan hat vielleicht dann
aber die menschen instrumentalisiert hat
zu ihren zwecken habe jedenfalls ohne
frage viel gesundheit usw
viele natürliche angenehme vorteile den
menschen verschafft hat das ist heute
die diskussion
jetzt gehen wir hier einfach mal den
text rhein in dieser grundlegung zur
metaphysik der sitten und ich muss
vielleicht noch was dazu sagen zu dem
titel metaphysik der sitten
das ist ja auch ein sehr seltsamer
begriff was bedeutet eigentlich
metaphysik der sitten
was ist denn eine metaphysik haben sie
da eine idee wie könnte man jetzt
metaphysik verstehen oder was verstehen
sie jetzt unter einem metaphysik der
sitten wenn sie diese zu lesen
sollte das jetzt nicht einfach so als
selbstverständlich hin stimmen was
könnte denn einen metaphysik der sitten
sein
also eine theorie die partie zwischen
stehen sein soll
genau so wie sie sein sollten
das wäre an diesem mittag diese
metaphysik tritt sodass normatives also
ist soll weg soll so seien wichtig und
jetzt einen schritt weiter noch was ist
dann der gegenstand der ethik ein oder
was ist dann das ethische eigentlich
wenn es das metaphysische ist wissen sie
das konkret also in welchem bereich
liegt nach kant dasjenige was für die
ethik relevant ist
genau das ist richtig also nach dem was
also was ist das ist natürlich das was
ist ist so die könnte man sagen so die
natur ins getriebe
man könnte auch sagen das empirische das
empirisch ist das was wir wahrnehmen das
was so die physik die physis ist nach
gladbach
das ist für kant nicht ausschlaggebend
für die ethik also irgend welche motive
die aus unserer natur stammen hunger
durst irgendwelche sinneswahrnehmung die
sind für kann nicht entscheidend für
etwas kritisches das was auch gut
genannt werden kann im moralischen sinne
sondern moralisch relevant ist bekannt
nur das was die vernunft betrieb damals
dann mit einem nahezu plattform sie
sehen ist als hier unten das hier diese
füße physis dieses sich verändernde ist
irrelevant für das gute und gut ist hier
so was was die natur übersteigt kann
sagt das ist die vernunft die vernunft
also letztendlich dasjenige was wir aus
unserem denken ziehen können ohne dass
unser denken dabei abhängig ist von der
erfahrung kennt nimmt das auch apriori a
priori ist lateinisch vor davor von
vornherein muss man dazu den vor der
erfahrung apriori von ersteren her vor
natürlichen hektar und davon
unterscheidet ihr das apostolische vom
späteren herren das spätere ist immer
die erfahrung also a priori und apostel
sind relations' begriffe und die biz
betrifft beziehen sich immer auf die
erfahrung
erfahrung also sinneswahrnehmung 19 es
pannen
das ist apriori und das ist ab austria
und apriori forever erfahrung ist nach
kann eben die vernunft unterdecke nach
kant kann so gedacht werden
das ist nicht von der sinneswahrnehmung
beeinträchtigt ist sondern ein reines
denken könnt uns reine begriffe also
rein logisch sachverhalte so ein
bisschen wie die mathematik so kann man
sich das vorstellen
und es ist dieses zieht damit er sich
dass ihnen also das gute ist verkannt
eine sehr logische angelegenheit erst
mal
man könnte jetzt sagen irgendwie ein
bisschen abstrakt aber bei kant schwebt
das jetzt nicht so wie bei platin
unseren ideen himmel rum sondern es
verdrückt gebunden an das subjekt an das
objekt an seinen willen also die ideen
die beziehen sich jetzt auf den
wählenden also unser wille muss um gut
zu sein um ethisch zu sein moralisches
sein muss er sich mit diesen ideen eine
verbindung setzen muss den sich die von
ihm er muss ich vernünftig bestimmen
lassen so muss man zwar dann wenn er
sich nicht von der vernunft bestimmen
lässt das ist also diese metaphysik die
metaphysik der sitten heißt wir können
es so sagt mitter wirke sich auch bei
platon der fall
metaphysik betrifft hier so die
ontologie die ideen darüber schwebt das
ist bei kant genauso nur kann bezieht
diese ideen diesen ganzen vernünftigen
überbau auf das subjekt auf den willen
und sagt gut ist dasjenige was den
willen soll jetzt endlich vernünftig und
empirisch bestimmt ist aber jetzt mal
vorweg genommen aber jetzt lesen einmal
genau den text was er das sagt noch eine
kleine anmerkung hier
das bedeutet akademie ausgabe h und das
ist der band
die bands aldi sagte mir ausgabe und
hier kommt dann die seitenzahlen so
zitierten bekannt immer dass sie sich
nicht wundern was das jetzt wohl wenn
sie in ihre hausarbeit schreiben wollen
sollten sie so kannte auch zitieren
immer nach der akademie ausgabe mit dem
berühmt mit dem römischen band und der
arabischen seitenzahl jetzt kann hier
ganz zu beginn das also ganz bekannte
passage er sagt ist es überall nichts in
der welt überhaupt auch aus derselben zu
denken möglich was ohne einschränkung
für gut könnte gehalten werden als
allein ein guter wille verstand witz
urteilskraft und wie die talente des
geistes sonst heißen mögen oder mut
entschlossenheit beharrlichkeit dem
vorsätze als eigenschaften des
temperaments sind ohne zweifel manche
absicht gut und wünschenswert aber sie
können auch äußerst böse und schädlich
werden wenn der wille der von diesen
natur gaben gebrauch machen soll und
dessen eigentümliche beschaffenheit
darum charakter heißt nicht gut ist
ok harald er sagt offenbar hat auch so
ein relativer begriff ist guten also es
gibt bestimmte dinge die sind gut aber
es gibt das beste das was ohne
einschränkung gut genannt werden kann
das beste das um was ist das jetzt
sagt er hier als er will und was ist der
grund
können sie das mal mit eigenen worten
wiedergeben was ist der grund warum
jetzt nach dem ersten zitat nur der
wille gut ist was könnte denn sonst doch
gut sein und was ist es aber nach kant
nicht
hinterher einige kandidaten noch die in
frage kämen kämen gut genannt werden zu
können
genau haben sie ein beispiel alle können
sie können sie ein beispiel geben oder
auch antritt wo so ein talent des
geistes eben nicht gut ist dann haben
sie die ja
hochintelligente psychopathen
ich denke da zum beispiel an schweigen
der lämmer kennen sie alle
der hört bach der hannibal lecter hört
bachs goldberg variationen wird er ihm
in seiner zelle und gleich er sieht auch
jetzt nicht als er sieht schon ein
bisschen komisch aussage ich mache ein
bisschen bisschen er ist kein monster
als er sieht nicht aus wie ein monster
gut mit dieser mast klettern um sein
gesicht herum sieht das schon sehr
unheimlich aus aber wenn man so sieht so
ein bisschen normal
und wenn man den film sich mal anschaut
dann merkt man der tut eigentlich ganz
selten etwas auffälliger blut heraus
oder aggression heraus sondern der geht
ziemlich intelligent vor er ist
hochintelligent auch die vorgeschichte
dieses es gibt ja verschiedene beendet
diese diese schweigen der lämmer ist ja
eigentlich eine amerikanische roman
trilogie oder weisen mehrere romane
das ist eine literarische vorlage der
film ist auf basis eines buches griff
und geführt
also produziert worden und man liest
also in diesen büchern das dir eben als
eine hoch intelligentes kind auch war
und natürlich eine schwere kindheit
hatte aber also wirklich total an
anerkannt von der gesellschaft usw
das nicht tun er hätte ja nicht alles er
hätte verstand witz brutales kraft und
viele andere talente des geistes er hat
natürlich auch mut entschlossenheit
beharrlichkeit dem vorsatz alles trifft
dort zu auf die ihn an fanny ballett
trotzdem ist er nicht gut
ja sie haben recht also heutzutage
spricht man medizinisch nicht mehr von
psychopathen das ist auch
aachen
naja ok
ah ja dann ist das ist interessant dann
ist also hannibal lecter doch ein
psychopath oder ok also spannende frage
spannende frage also sie sehen ja kann
man sehr noch unterscheiden
entscheidend ist dass es konzern
telegent entriss und dass eben diese
ganzen talente des geistes bei hannibal
lecter sehr sehr böse gebraucht werden
und deswegen kann so ein talent nicht
gut genannt werden an sich es kann gut
genannt werden einem instrument allen
sinnen
natürlich ist für hannibal lecter sein
verstand gut weil er damit seinen
verbrecherischen absichten gut verfolgen
kann aber vorausgesetzt wird diesen
diesem diesem talent eben eine absicht
und die absicht ist es entscheidend und
nicht das talent als zeugnisse also
hannibal lecter hätte genau diese
talente des geistes die kontinent und
wir würden ihn gerade deswegen nicht gut
nennen weil er diese talente alle in
ihrer perfektion vielleicht sogar böse
einsetzt hoch intelligent total
entschlossen total organisiert ja nicht
schlampig überhaupt nicht sehr
ordentlich kultiviert ist auch noch
kultiviert trotzdem ist nicht gut
entscheiden deshalb was hinter diesen
diesen eigenschaften diesen talenten
steht
sie können nämlich äußerst böse und
schädlich werden wenn der wille das
nicht ist und das ist bei an die palette
der fall für die clubs gaben ist ebenso
gewand macht reichtum ihrer selbst
gesundheit und das ganze wohlbefinden
und zufriedenheit mit seinem zustand
unter dem namen der glückseligkeit heute
harmoniert
machen mut und hierdurch öfters auch
übermut wo nicht ein guter wille da ist
der den einfluss der sieben aufs gemüt
und hiermit auch das ganze prinzip zu
handeln berechtige und allgemein
zweckmäßig mache ohne zu erwähnen dass
ein vernünftiger unparteiischer
zuschauer circa im augenblick eines
goldenen wohlergehens eines wesens das
kein zug eines reinen guten willens
ziert nimmermehr ein wohlgefallen haben
kann und vor der gute wille die uhr nach
unerlässliche bedingung selbst der
würdigkeit glücklich zu sein auszumachen
scheint okay also hier haben wir jetzt
rückgaben glückseligkeit
das ist alles total dass im hintergrund
alles total sagt das beste gut ist die
glückseligkeit wenn wir glücklich sind
oder sagt kant war ja aber sich jetzt
direkt auf aristoteles bezieht es die
frage aber das schwebt schon bis im
hintergrund glückseligkeit ist nicht an
sich gut sondern auch bei der
glückseligkeit muss ein wille dahinter
stehen der verhindert dass die
glückseligkeit den übermut umschlägt sie
kennen das alles wenn man sehr happy ist
oder im lotto gewonnen hat und so weiter
gerade dann passieren einen die
blödesten dinge dann rast man vom casino
nach hause mit seinem auto ist zu
schnell ist übermütig und bauten unfall
unverletzt vielleicht person ist schon
mal vorgekommen habe ich schon mal
gelesen nachrichten also was vorkamen
also glückseligkeit in sich sagt kant
muss gelenkt werden
diese dieser mut ist diese zufriedenheit
die verbirgt nicht an sich schon das
gute
die muss kontrolliert werden
es braucht ein prinzip kann es auch noch
richtig ein prinzip zu handeln als er
kann dass das gute immer auch mit einem
prinzip verbunden das ist ganz wichtig
es muss geregelt sein das prinzip ist
die vernunft letztendlich
und dann zeigt kann sogar noch ein
unparteiischer zuschauer kann im anblick
eines ununterbrochenen wohlergehens
harmonie eines wesens das kein zug eines
rein und guten willens ziert nimmermehr
ein wohlgefallen haben und so der gute
wille die unerlässliche bedingung selbst
würdigkeit glücklich zu sein auto
mannschaft was ist damit gemeint
verstehen sie das war jetzt kommt schon
das kind einen vorgriff die theorie das
höchste gut bei kantinen spiel was ist
hier die kritik was sagt er jetzt hier
warum ist glückseligkeit nach kant nicht
an sich gut aus der perspektive eines
anderen land nun parteiischer zuschauer
woran könnte der sich stoßen bei einem
glückseligen menschen unter welchen
bedingungen könnte eher sagen
der verdient gar nicht die clips ihr
nicht gereicht
oder unter welchen bedingungen könnten
parteiischer zuschauer ein amanda
antrieb personen die glückseligkeit
nicht gönnen
aber stuttgart
ein zuschauer der aber urteil dass der
anwender keine
da
ja also ich denke er meint damit ein
objektiven zuschauer also jemand der ins
innere des anderen schauen kann also
jemand der sieht er ist jemand
glückselig da hat jemand viel glück
ununterbrochen das wohlergehen nur glück
gehabt im leben aber für die moralisch
sie kennen dieses dilemma wieso geht es
dem unmoralischen mancher bessere alte
moralischen das ist die frage sollte
mich eigentlich derjenige der gutes auch
glückselig seien häufig verkannt ist es
gerade andersherum
der ehrliche ist der dumme kurz gesagt
der sich moral amoralische gebote hält
der schränkt seine glückseligkeit ein
würden auch viele hedonisten oder
nietzsche oder so sagen warum moralisch
sein bringt doch gar nichts kann man
kritisieren bringt uns doch vielleicht
erstmal gar nichts an glücks gehaben
lassen
wir schränken uns doch nur ein
schlechtes gewissen mehr leiden darunter
darum sollten wir uns von so einem
moralischen gebot überhaupt bestimmen
lassen
es sind wir werden aber nicht glücklich
dadurch haben viele gesagt
doch keinen
das wird mir jungen kommen
richtig aber indem wir uns an
moralischen geboten ausrichten und
design zum ziel unseres handelns machen
laufen wir gefahr immer wieder
gewissensbisse zu haben weil wir dieses
moralische bot anerkennen wir merken uns
einig wollen wir es gar nicht in manchen
situationen jedenfalls und dann kommt
der gewissensbisse oder also jedenfalls
wenn wir dieses moralische gebot
anerkennen dann haben wir das problem
blick gewissensbisse wenn wir es nicht
anerkennen wenn du uns die moral egal
ist dann haben wir auch keine
gewissensbisse lohnen könnte ja genau
ich glaube auch nicht dass es so was
gibt aber es könnte könnte ja sein
könnte ja sagen die moral ist nur ein
konstrukt ist nur ein kulturelles
produkt der evolution und was immer von
sozialen gemeinschaften und relativismus
hier auf der welt gelten diese norm
nicht das ist so ein übliches argumente
und es könnte jetzt an menschen geben
eine person geben die neben der die
moral egal ist die auch völlig
unmoralisch handelt aus der perspektive
eines objektiven betrachters der die
moral sondern vor augen hat und es
könnte sein dass diese person obwohl sie
nie moralisch gehandelt hat immer glück
hat gewinnt im lotto ist gesetz und
keine krankheiten ist er gescheitert
viele natur gaben
obwohl er die moral egal das obwohl sie
nicht moralisch ist und dann sagt kant
in so einem fall würde unparteiischer
zuschauer wenn er weiß dass da kein
guter wille zu grunde liegt kein
wohlgefallen haben können der findet der
würde dann nicht sympathie haben mit
dieser glückseligen personen
er würde sogar sagen vielleicht sie ist
eigentlich gar nicht glückselig richtig
bei um wirklich glücklich zu sein
moralität noch hinzukommen ist und diese
idee der wirklichen glückseligkeit die
der unparteiische zuschauer verlangt
implizit diese idee wird kann dann im
nächsten text das höchste gut nehmen
sexy gut ist dann also die
proportionalität von moralität und
glückseligkeit also die höchste gut ist
die idee dass nur der jemand irgendwie
hat man so dass gegen die der moralisch
ist das nicht durch gewissensbisse
geplagt wird oder irgendwie sonst nur
irgendwelche nachteile hat also der
dumme ist weil er ehrlich ist sondern
dass der im endeffekt in letzer hinsicht
auch glückselig sein muss so gesagt dass
eine forderung der vernunft kann sagt in
uns ist die forderung enthalten unsere
vernunft das ist einig zu sein müsste es
soll dass es sein das angebot normativ
dass der der moralisch handeln
eigentlich auch glückselig sein sollte
er hat es verdient auch wenn es sich de
facto in der welt sich so in den
seltensten fällen verhält ich meine es
gibt durchaus die fälle wo man sagt es
habe ich hab' ich bin mit mir im reinen
ich habe ein reines gewissen und das
macht mich zufrieden
ich muss zwar dann verzichten auf
einiges aber dass so eine weisheit oder
so aber es gibt eben auch die fälle wo
das jetzt vielleicht nicht zur
glückseligkeit führt weil man irgendwie
anlegt oder weil man bestraft wird oder
so wenn man sich für das gute eingesetzt
hat wenn es denn das gute als die es
gibt und da sagt kann da fordern unsere
vernunft dass das belohnt wird auch wenn
es im irdischen dasein letztendlich
vielleicht nicht belohnt wird
das ist also die idee des höchsten gutes
klingt hier schon an die implizite also
sagt einer aus der perspektive eines
unparteiischen zuschauer könnten können
die bloße glückseligkeit als sich wenn
sie nicht passiert oder fundiert ist in
einem moralischen willen nie dieses
wohlgefallen ausführten beim betrachter
weiter gehts einige eigenschaften sind
sogar diesen guten willen selbst
befördert lich und können sein werk sehr
erleichtern haben aber dem ungeachtet
keinen unbedingten wert sondern setzen
immer noch einen guten willen voraus der
die hochschätzung die man übrigens mit
recht für sie trägt einschränkt und es
nicht erlaubt sie verschlechtert und zu
halten
ermäßigungen effekten und leidenschaften
selbstbeherrschung und nüchtern
überlegung sind nicht allein in
vielerlei absicht gut sondern scheint
sogar ein teil von den inneren werte der
person auszumachen allein es fehlt viel
daran um sie ohne einschränkung für gut
zu erklären so unbedingt sie auch von
den alten gepriesen worden sind denn
ohne grundsätze eines guten willens
können sie höchst böse werden und das
kalte blut eines bösewichts macht ihnen
nicht allein weit gefährlicher sind auch
unmittelbar in unseren augen noch
verabscheuungswürdiger als er ohne
dieses dafür würde gehalten werden als
er wieder ganz viele informationen
welche begriffe sind ihnen jetzt
besonders ins auge gestochen oder haben
sie noch bezüge gefunden so philosophen
die wir bereits behandelt hatten dieses
zitat ist sehr reich an bezügen
auf was spielt denn jetzt könnt ihr an
wenn er von eigenschaften spricht
hier beispiele gibt hier in der fünften
zeile in der sechsten zeile mäßigung
effekten und leidenschaften
selbstbeherrschung und nüchtern
überlegungen würden sie denn so etwas
nennen mäßigung
was ist das für eine qualität wenn sie
sagen diese person ist gemäßigt was
sprechen sie dann eine person zu ja ja
das ist auch ein fall dieser kategorie
die jetzt das thema ist ja genau
sind tugenden forfour söhne ist die ist
kritischen heißt die besonnenheit
mäßiges ots ist die mäßigung gibt die
mitte das spielt auf aristoteles an der
hatte ja auch haben wir kurz behandelt
und seinen text wird das gute gesagt das
gute hängt auch mit den tugenden
zusammen als selbstbeherrschung und so
weiter sofort das sind mäßig und
effekten dass diese mittels lehre also
diese aus mittelung kein extrem das soll
nicht übermäßig in beide richtungen
ausschlag in jeder hinsicht mehr wir
sollen nicht zu kühl sein
es sollen aber auch nicht zu feige sein
sollen wir sollen einfach über besonnen
sein das ist die beste tugend für einen
feldherrn zum beispiel weder zu kühn
einfach gleich nach vorn stöhr mit dem
heer noch gleich reißaus nehmen und
überlegen abwägen und dann eine kluge
entscheidung treffen dass die
besonnenheit
das team ist es die die ja die aus
mitteilungen könnten uns sagen
und jetzt sagt aber kann auch dass hogan
als solche verbirgt nicht das gute weil
vielleicht sogar hannibal lecter auch
tun hat ist auch ein sehr besonderer
mensch also eher reagiert die effekt
wenn sie dieses ziel vor augen haben er
macht alles sehr langsam sehr bedächtig
das ist es ist total tugendhaft wenn man
sie jetzt mal so eng sieht jedenfalls
könnte man sagen er selbst beherrscht
jedenfalls
dazu trägt auch bei diesem musik gehört
ich sage es einmal die goldberg
variationen von bach das sind sehr wohl
komponierte sehr harmonische stücke sehr
intelligent also wirklich feinster
intellektueller genuss und da stimmt er
sich ein mit diesen goldberg variationen
er ist total fast schon meditativ diese
110 jahren
trotzdem sagt kann bringt nichts kann
auch so nüchtern sein
es fehlt was immer noch dran was ohne
einschränkungen gut erklärt werden
könnte und jetzt sagt kant was wieder
entscheidend ist ohne grundsätze eines
guten willens grundsatzes dass
entscheiden können diese tugenden wieder
höchst böse werden wie im falle von
hannibal lecter das kalte blut eines
bösewichts macht ihn nicht allein weit
gefährlicher sondern auch unmittelbar in
unseren augen noch
verabscheuungswürdiger als er ohne
dieses dafür würde gehalten werden hier
gibt's wieder bezug zum vorherigen zutat
wo kann von einem prinzip spricht hier
das ganze prinzip
prinzip zu handeln ein grundsatz das ist
auch wieder das von dem an diesem zitat
hier spricht ein grundsatz den grundsatz
eines guten willens und das ist dann
letztendlich die ontologie die
gerontologie denn das haben einige für
ihn auch schon essays gemacht hat jemand
von ihnen noch ein protokoll geschrieben
auf dass er keine rückmeldung bekommen
hat bisher noch nicht okay in diesem in
diesem hinweis auf den grundsatz auf das
prinzip
darin liegt die kantige unter logi also
diese theologische ethik ist kommt geht
um ein sollen meine pflicht mein prinzip
das ist die der ontologie die
ontologische tätig wären der
utilitarismus von anderen denkt an die
noch kommen oder vielleicht party bei
aristoteles aber das würde ich jetzt
nicht sagen sie heute ein juristisch
tätig wobei die sozialistisch oder
konsequenz ist ischen ewigen nicht so
sehr auf das prinzip schauen
das prinzip dass diese handlung zugrunde
legt den willen sondern die schauen auf
die folgen
was kam dabei raus also hier sehen sie
eben durch diesen hinweis auf den
grundsatz auf das prinzip dass keine
theologische ethik vertritt
also paradox jemand der im bösen gerade
besonnen ist der besonders tugendhaft
gewesen ist der wird dadurch nicht
besser sondern gerade noch böser fehler
tugendhaft drin ist würden sie doch auch
sagen der größte gruß die größten großen
effekt haben sie nicht in filmen wenn da
jetzt einfach so ein monster kommt
vielleicht schon auf den ersten blick
aber wenn sie mal die gesamte spannung
des filmes betrachten dann würden sie
irgendwann gelangweilt werden wenn jede
minute ein neues monster käme auch von
der ecke hervor so ein monster cable
sollen besonders spannend ist es dann
wenn sie mehr da ist ein akteur damit
person die eigentlich böse ist aber die
die anderen täuscht die sich versteckt
die mit anderen ein spiel spielt die die
anderen messer laufen ist das scheint
jedenfalls mir viel spannender zu sein
als so ein plus an monster für die
traumatologie da ist eine spannende und
ich denke so ist es auch hier möchte
kann auch sagen
der gute wille weiter geht's ins nicht
nur dass durch das was er bewirkt oder
ausrichtet ich durch seine tauglichkeit
zur erreichung irgend eines vorgesetzten
zweckes sind allein durch das wollen das
heißt an sich gut und für sich selbst
betrachtet ohne vergleich weit höher zu
schätzen als alles was durch ihn
zugunsten irgendeinen neigung ja wenn
man will der summe aller neigungen nur
immer zustande gebracht werden könnte
wenngleich durch eine besondere und
gunst des schicksals oder durch tägliche
ausstattung einer stiefmütterlichen
natur ist diesen willen gänzlich an
vermögen fehlte seine absicht
durchzusetzen wenn bei seiner größten
bestrebung der noch nicht von ihm
ausgerichtet wurde und nur der gute
wille freilich nicht etwa als eine bloße
wunsch sein als die aufbietung aller
mittel
in unserer gewalt sind übrig bliebe
so würde er wie ein juwel doch für sich
selbst glänzen als etwas das seinen
vollen wert in sich selbst hat die
möglichkeit oder fruchtlose ich kann
diese werte weder etwas zu setzen noch
abnehmen
sie würden gleichsam nur die einfassung
sein um ihn dem gemein verkehr besser
handhaben zu können oder die
aufmerksamkeit der die noch nicht genug
kenner sind auf sich zu ziehen
nicht aber um ihn kennen zu empfehlen
und seinen wert zu bestimmen hier ist
jetzt auch wieder ein ganz zentrales
zitat und zwar kommt jetzt hier gleich
zu beginn die abgrenzung von einer
anderen ethischen position
wie lautet die können sie dir nochmal
wiedergeben sagt der gute wille ist
nicht durch das was er bewirkt oder
ausrichtet nicht durch seine
tauglichkeit zu erreichen eines
vorgesetzten zweckes zu allein durch das
wollen
das heißt an sich gut es wäre jetzt sind
entgegengesetzte position dazu
die anderen
genau die utilitaristische oder
konsequenz ils muss es geht nicht darum
was der wille bewirkt sollen darum wie
der wille beschaffen ist die quantität
zu ihr die qualität des bildes liegt die
konsequenzen und die innere struktur
und er gibt es wieder so ein beispiel
ins 16 wenngleich durch eine besonders
besonderen gunst des schicksals durch
kärgliche ausstattung einer
stiefmütterlich natur aus diesem elend
gänzlich an vermögen fehlte seine
absicht durchzusetzen
bei der seiner größten bestrebungen der
noch nichts von ihm ausgerichtet wurde
und nur der gute wille freilich nicht
etwa seine dose wohnens als die
aufbietung aller mittels zweit ziehen
und zwei gewalt sind übrig blieb so
würde er wie ein juwel doch für sich
selbst grenzen als etwas zu sein wollen
wir selbst in sich hat die nützlichkeit
oder frucht losigkeit also die
konsequenz die nützlichkeit oder
misserfolg kann diese werte wieder etwas
im gegensatz zum abnehmen jetzt kommt
die metapher ist also eine metapher sie
würde gleich nur die einfassung sein
wissen sie was eine einfassung ist ein
juwel der einfassung
so wie es jetzt die metaphorik lassen
wir das mal hier bildlich ein bisschen
uns besser vorstellen können
ich habe mir den juwel
geschliffen und was ist jetzt die
einfassung
wie kann man sich das jetzt vorstellen
was ist eine einfassung von dem juden
oder von einem edelstein
ja
sinsheim
so irgendwie zu lassen so könnt ihr dann
auch hier so ein bonbon machen
ca
vorletzter hier das hier ist der gute
wille
er will jetzt endlich dass hier die
einfassung ist die handlung oder die
konsequenz
konsequenz des fühlens
als entscheid und sie würden auch sagen
ja gut die einfassung hin oder her
die mache ich wenn die einfassung wenn
ich mir gefällt des juwels mache ich
eine andere einfassung darum jetzt mal
silber oder gold oder platin oder
irgendwie sowas aber es kommt auf den
juwel an dass das entscheidende die
einfassung ist nur was äußerliches
äußerlich kalt oder akzidenz hatte nur
was äußerlich hinzu kommt dass das macht
den wert des juwels sich aus sie kaufen
den juwel auch wenn er in der einfassung
hat die nicht gefällt auch wenn eine
messing einfassung hat
in st
der wilde berichtet sich etwas
und das scheint der handlungen gegen
windkraft aber ein
und zwar deswegen weil er jetzt hier
dieses gedanken beispiel bringt in der
sechsten zeile wenngleich durch eine
besondere gunst des schicksals oder
durch tägliche ausstellung eine
stiefmütterliche natur ist diesem wie in
gänze an vermögen fehlt er seine absicht
durchzusetzen
was auch immer man sich darunter
vorstellen können was kann man sich
darunter vorstellen
inwiefern könnte es durch eine
ungünstige ausstattung der natur den
willen daran mangeln seine absicht
durchzusetzen
wie kann man sich das vorstellen haben
sie die idee
ich denke es geht in die richtige
richtung aber er hätte ja schon seinen
willen durchgesetzt der wille wer jetzt
halt nur ein inter will obwohl er
eigentlich gutes motiv hatte er kommt ja
zur handlung der münchen glaubt hier
das gar nicht nutzen wenn er
ich denke
noch gut
ich denke dass sklaven beispiel trifft
recht gut der sklave hatten sich den
guten willen
aber er hat nicht die handlungsfreiheit
er hat willensfreiheit das hatten wir
schon mal glaube ich diskutiert bekannt
sein willen bestimmen
aber er kann diesen willen nicht zur
wirklichkeit werden lassen weil
ungünstige umstände die daran hindern
man könnte sich das jetzt auch so
vorstellen dass die hindern umstände
nicht äußerlich sind sondern innerlich
halt das scheint mir jetzt hier ihr
gemeinsam haben wir dann von einer
kärglichen ausstattung einer
stiefmütterlichen natur diese
stiefmütterliche natur kann man jetzt
als seine sklaven gesellschaft
interpretieren die es eine person
ermöglicht seiner handlung zu kommen
obwohl der wille gebildet wurde oder man
könnte sich überlegen könnte es personen
geben die willensschwach sind phänomene
willensschwäche wie also sieht sich nun
wunsch haben sagte auch nicht ein bloßer
wunsch jetzt wünsche ich mir dass
halbmast so sehr sagt mit voller
aufbietung der kräfte als ich will es
wirklich ich möchte es zu entscheidungen
kommen lassen und wo dann irgendwie doch
eine schwäche drin ist
das muss man sich jetzt genau so schön
wie kann man sich das so vorstellen das
ist kein großer wunsch ist ein wille
also die aufbietung aller mittel so weit
zu unserer gewalt sind
ja
da schaut man es sagen
was tun
ich denke es ein gutes beispiel
also bei psychischen einschränkungen
sagt jetzt mal da kann dann auch so ein
wille in der tendenz da sein aber es
kann einfach dann sowieso eine
willenskraft fehlen also eine psychische
stärke kann fehlen der wille markt
gebildet worden sein die psychische
stärke ist das selbstbewusstsein ist
nicht mehr stark genug um dann den
willen tatsächlich auszuüben und das
wäre nicht nur bloße wohl schon das wäre
durchaus ein will aber der hat sehr sehr
ein schwaches durch fehlende innere
stärke und kann egal selbst in solchen
fällen
der wille ist gut also ist damit alles
schlucken
wir brauchen da nicht da bemängeln
kritisieren dass es nicht zum behandlung
kam
wir wissen den grund der grund das
prinzip ist vorhanden also kann man es
gut nennen so argumentiert kann
es liegt jetzt kommt zum ersten mal
bekannt er verwendet diesen betrieb sehr
selten der begriff des absoluten er sagt
nie das absolute er substantiiert nicht
das absolute das machen dann erst andere
das macht eine schelling stellen spricht
vom das unbedingt also kann spricht hier
immer klein
also ich gehe noch mal zurück hier hier
hier in zeile 3 unbedingter wert also
immer nur sein prädikat bekannt absolut
unbedingt ins fried bei shell in den
ganzen deutschen etat listen sozusagen
also schelling fichte schelling hegel
vor allem hegel da werden dann diese
bloßen prädikate diese kleingeschrieben
attribute substantiven schelling spricht
von dem unbedingt schilling möchten
sondern würde sowie vom unbedingten
ausgehen regel spricht von dem absoluten
als substantive das absolut es gibt es
bei kant noch nicht
es ist nur so als kleine
hintergrundinformation bekannt gibt es
natürlich das absolute das ist der wille
das absolute wenn man so will ist der
gute wille aber kann man das lied es
absolut er sagt immer nur satten
absoluten wert sie gleichwohl in dieser
idee von dem absoluten werte des bloßen
willens ohne einige nutzen bei schätzung
des selben in anziehung zu bringen etwas
so befremdliches das unerwartet alle
einstimmung selbst der gemeinen vernunft
mit derselben der noch ein verdacht
entspringen muss das vielleicht bloß
hochfliegende fantasterei insgeheim zum
grunde liege und die natur in ihrer
absicht warum sie unseren willen
vernunft zu regieren beigelegt habe
falsch verstanden sein möge daher wollen
wir diese idee aus diesem gesichtspunkt
haus auf die prüfung stellen
ich habe jetzt interessant macht sich
jetzt selbst ein einwand er könnte sagen
ja also diese rede von unbedingtem
absolut und so das könnte das klingt
doch jetzt also mal sehr seltsam
also so ein willen der ja gar nicht
greifbar ist und der wille existiert
nicht der wille ist ein prinzip in uns
wir spüren ihn aber wir sehen ihn nicht
macht sich nicht direkt als konkrete
handlung bemerkbar muss es auch nicht um
gut zu sein
wir reden darüber so ein hirngespinst
könnte jetzt könnte man sagen sagt
braucht kann selbst ein bisschen ist es
nicht nur eine hochfliegende fantasterei
und jetzt will er diesen gedanken mal
ein bisschen mehr erklären das ist jetzt
nur so eine eingangs metaphorik also
sehr metaphernreich das ist eine
metapher ist eine metapher oder
vergleich aber er sagt nicht also im
vergleich wäre das damals sein würde
der wille entspricht ein juwel das sagt
er so nicht direkt
der wille ist der juwel oder so aber
nicht entspricht und wenn er jetzt nicht
direkt es verhält sich so wie der wille
ist wie ein juwel wenn er das nicht so
explizit sagt dann ist es eine metapher
wenn aber das vergleicht den vergleich
des vergleichs partikel bringt dann wäre
ein vergleich ist eine metapher und
jetzt wieder diese metapher dir jetzt
uns sehr geschickt einfach mal bildlich
vorgeführt hat das will er jetzt
vernünftig begrifflich beweisen wurde
analysieren warum es denn so ist hat
jetzt ein paar intuitiv argumente
gebracht aber will das jetzt noch ganz
analytisch uns darlegen
und jetzt lesen wir weiter gehen die
natur anlagen eines organisierten dh
zweckmäßig zum leben eingerichteten
wesens nehmen wir es als grundsatz dass
kein werkzeug zu irgendeinem zweck in
demselben angetroffen werke werde als
was auch zu demselben das schädlichste
und ihm am meisten angemessen ist wäre
nun an einem wesen das sonst in einen
willen hat seine haltung sein
wohlergehen mit einem wurde seine
glückseligkeit der eigentliche zweck der
natur aristoteles so ein bisschen
hintergrund so hätte sie ihre
veranstaltung dazu sehr schlecht
getroffen sich die vernunft des
geschäfts zur ausrichterin diese ihre
arbeit zu ersehen denn alle handlungen
die es in dieser absicht auszuüben hat
wohnt die ganze regel seines verhaltens
würden ihm weit genauer durch instinkt
vorgezeigt und jeder zweck weit sichere
dadurch haben erhalten werden können als
es jemals durch vernunft geschehen kann
und sollte diese ja oben ein den
begünstigten geschöpf erteilt worden
sein
so würde sie ihm nur dazu haben dienen
müssen um über die glückliche anlage ist
seiner natur betrachtungen anzustellen
sie zu bewundern sie ihre sie ihre zu
erfreuen und der wohltätigen ursache
dafür dankbar zu sein nicht aber um
seinen regierungsvermögen jener
schwachen untrüglichen leitung zu
unterwerfen und in der natur absicht zu
pushen mit einem wort das sie würde
verhütet haben dass vernunft nicht im
praktischen gebrauch einschläge und die
vermessenheit hätte mit ihrem ihren
schwachen einsichten ihr selbst ein
entwurf der glückseligkeit und ermittelt
dazu gelangen auszudenken die natur
würde nicht allein die wahl der zwecke
sondern auch der mittel selbst
übernommen und beide mit weise vorsorge
lediglich dem instinkte anvertraut haben
was sagt er jetzt hier verbringt jetzt
nicht gegen vorstellung ins spiel
also die these ist wie im vorherigen
zitat gesagt hat möchte das beweisen das
die natur den willen die von uns zur
regierung beigelegt hat die natur ist
jetzt nicht die empirische natur sondern
das ist halt in abo des menschen
es verhält sich beim menschen so dass
die natur dass der wille
die vorgaben von der vernunft hält oder
erhalten soll vielleicht besser gesagt
und nicht von der natur im engeren sinne
nicht von den trieben und so weiter und
so fort so warum ist das jetzt so er
sagt eigentlich ist es doch eher
unplausibel dass der wille die vernunft
als regieren oder als light instanz
vorgesetzt bekommen soll
warum was ist ein grund warum ist das
ihr seltsam erstmal auf ersten blick
zumindest ein 15 6 die zahlen
auch ein bisschen der mitte
mit dem alter und der unsere gute
konter für st
der kapitän
es wurde in unserer hand vom 17
in unserem handeln
wichtig also sagen die vernunft muss
irgendwie der natur jetzt unsere
sinnlichkeit uns unsere gefühle unsere
neigung usw kontrollieren
jetzt könnte man aber sagen es sagt auch
kant warum denn überhaupt weil
eigentlich hat uns doch die natur so
eingerichtet dass unser instinkt schon
genau weiß was wir wollen also wir haben
hunger wir haben gewisse bedürfnisse und
wir kommen schon dazu die bedürfnis zu
befriedigen
das geht schon irgendwie wieso brauchen
wir da die vernunft sollten wir dann
nicht uns einfach nur der natur hingeben
letztendlich wenn es um unsere erhaltung
geht wir in 25 sagt hier die haltung die
glückseligkeit dann sollten wir sollten
wir dann nicht mehr fragt kann auf die
natur in uns horchen
ich habe dieses bedürfnis ich habe diese
lust in mir warum soll dann die vernunft
noch dazwischenfunken wollten wir
irgendwie sagen das sollst du und das
nicht diese diesen trieb soll es nach
gehen und diese nicht am besten ich höre
doch gar nicht auf die vernunft so nur
auf meine inneren bedürfnisse dann ist
doch meine selbsterhaltung und meine
glückseligkeit die größte es würde sagt
es kann also gegen einfach
in seiner tour bestätigt so ausdrücken
sondern
tja das ist völlig richtig kann sagt
also das leere etwas zu kurz gegriffen
eben nur von dieser natur auszugehen die
unmittelbare triebbefriedigung bedeutet
das dass es völlig richtig kant geht in
diese richtung das erlebt uns nicht sagt
weiter in der tat finden wir auch dass
sie mehr eine kultivierte vernünftig mit
der absicht auf den genuss des lebens
und der glückseligkeit ab gibt es zur
weiter der mensch von der wahren
zufriedenheit abkommen daraus bei 42 den
verrücktesten gebrauche das eben wenn
sie nur aufrichtig genug sind es zu
gestehen ein gewisser grad von biologie
dh hass der vernunft entspringt weil sie
nach dem überschlag alles vorteils den
sie ich will nicht sagen
von der erfindung aller künste des
gemeinde sondern sogar von den
wissenschaften die ihn am ende auch ein
luxus des verständnisses sagen zu sein
scheinen ziehen dennoch finden dass es
sich in der tat nur mehr mühseligkeit
auf den hals gezogen als an
glückseligkeit gewonnen haben und
darüber endlich den gemeinen schlag der
menschen welcher der leitung des bloßen
natur instinkts mehr ist und der seiner
vernunft nicht viel einfluss auf sein
tun und lassen versteht ihr beneiden als
gering schätzen und so weit muss man
gestehen dass das urteil derer die die
ruhige hochpreisigen der vorurteile die
uns die vernunft in ansehung der
glückseligkeit und zufriedenheit des
lebens verschaffen sollte sehr mäßigen
und sogar unter null herabsetzen
keineswegs cremig oder gegen die güte
der weltregierung und dankbar sind dass
diesen urteilen insgeheim die idee von
einer anderen und das ist ihr punkt und
viel würdigeren absicht ihre existenz im
grunde liege zur welcher und nicht der
glückseligkeit die vernunft ganz
eigentlich bestimmt sei und welche darum
als webers der bedingung die privat
absicht des menschen größtenteils nach
stehen muss das ist ein sehr
komplizierter satz so formuliert kann
leider immer wieder sehr lange sätze und
weiß am ende gar nicht mehr was der
anfang
man verliert den faden das versuchte
denn jetzt hier zu zeigen
es geht also genau in ihre richtung da
sie sagten ja der mensch ist schon
natürliches wesen er hat schon natürlich
interessen aber hat auch ein vernunft
interesse in sich
können sie daraus einen gewinn aus
diesem zitat ist ein bisschen unklar was
er da sagen möchte
diesen drei zeilen die leute denen es
ein ganz sagt dass je mehr eine
kultivierte vernünftig mit der absicht
auf den genuss des lebens und der
glückseligkeit ab gibt desto weiter der
mensch von der wahren zufriedenheit
abkommen haben sie dann beispiel wie
kann uns das vorstellen
das ist letztendlich gibt einen tipp das
ist ganz im sinne von rousseaus vernunft
zustande
was passiert dann wenn jetzt die
vernunft in den dienst unserer
glückseligkeit gestellt wird was
passiert denn das kann dann passieren
denken sie mal an die vernunft zustand
den wir ganz kurz behandelt hatten
wenn sie jetzt ihre vernunft zu
kultivieren dass sie nur dafür einsetzen
ihre glückseligkeit zu vergrößern
was was ist dann im endeffekt das
problem
münchen
genau
sie haben sich noch gemeldet
richtig handeln und der schweiz
das ist auch richtig aber was können
denn die konsequenzen sein warum könnte
das gerade in einem iso logi der
vernunft umschlagen
sie haben es eigentlich schon beide auch
gesagt das problem ist halt
wir vergleichen uns immer mit anderen
wir vergleichen uns wenn wir unsere
vernunft auf das c leg seligkeit richten
dann gibt es halt immer jemand der noch
glücklicher als ich die person hat mehr
als ich person ist reicher schöner und
so weiter als ich und das wurde auch
heute habe ich neidgefühlen ein
vergleich nicht ständig eine kultivierte
vernünftig der natur erfolgt die das
ziel der glückseligkeit hat die wird
mich antreiben und die wird mich im
endeffekt unzufriedener machen es
erkannt weil sie mich in mir immer
wieder vorhalten wird rational so
quantitativ diese person hat mehr in
dieser hinsicht so weit ich bin
schlechter und so weiter und so fort
das ist die vernunft auch nichts wenn
wir es erkannt wenn es sie in den dienst
der glückseligkeit stellen wenn wir sie
von der natur von als wenn wir sie als
eine instrumentelle vernunft sehen die
nur mittel zum zweck und gibt weil dann
können wir immer weiter vergleichen und
so weiter und selbst wenn es uns
eigentlich gut geht geben wir uns
erkannt damit vielleicht nicht zufrieden
weil es könnte uns noch besser gehen die
vernunft sagt mir das musst du noch tun
um noch zufriedener zu werden du bist
immer nicht perfekt glückselig
das problem ist eine kultivierte
vernunft die sich in den dienst der
glückseligkeit stellt wird nie zu etwas
absolut im kommen können sie wird nie in
sich ruhen es jetzt immer wieder was
noch teureres schöneres und so weiter
denken dass absolute gibt es nicht in
diesem bereich
der glückseligkeit sagt krank diese
natürlichen glückseligkeit ist absolute
dieses ende wo die von zufrieden ist in
sich ruht und sich immer weiter antreibt
und uns unzufrieden werden lässt so wie
in russischen von uns zustand dieses
absolute das gibt's nicht in der natur
hatte nicht im sinne dieser
glückseligkeit sondern es gibt es nun
sinne der moralität das absolute diese
diese hohe diese innere diesen endpunkt
diese erfüllung des ziels dieses tellers
was erfüllt ist das haben wir nur
moralischen wenn wir guten willen haben
dann ist ja an sich gut die handlung ist
egal weil wenn mit wenn die handlung der
rolle spielen würde würde wieder diese
quantitative vernünftige menschen mit
rein kommen ja wie groß ist der nutzen
und sofort den nutzen könnt ihr noch
größer sein oder muss ich mich noch mehr
anstrengen usw dann komme ich schon
wieder weg vom absoluten kann möchte
dieses absolute gerade irgendwie
begründen er sagt es gibt nichts auf der
welt was an und für sich gut genannt
werden könnte als ein guter wille im
guten will der ist so völlig unbedeutend
der ist gar nicht sichtbar
der glänzt in sich im stillen ganz
bescheiden tugendhaft sind nicht mal das
tor technischen sinne der glänzt in sich
der leucht er strahlt ohne dass es das
dazu großer krone eines großen aufwand
bedürftige gibt uns diese innere
selbstzufriedenheit erkannt
und
letztendlich hat damit kommt auch dass
diese aristotelische theorie so scheint
es jedenfalls die gegen das gut in der
glückseligkeit das sieht in diesen
stellen diesem streben der erfüllung des
tellers dass die sed der natürlichen
glückseligkeit heute harmonia
letztendlich in sich widersprüchlich ist
weil wir wenn wir dazu die fünf
gebrauchen nie zu einer wirklichen
glückseligkeit kommen können würde kann
es sagen also ein solcher begriff von
glückseligkeit der auf die erfüllung von
zwecken gericht ist die nicht
moralischer natur sind jetzt in sich
widersprüchlich natürlich sagt
aristoteles muss man auch sehen dass
sagt letztendlich das moralische leben
das praktische leben natürlich auch das
höchste theoretische leben die schau des
absoluten dass das die höchste
glückseligkeit ist aristoteles hat das
natürlich gesehen dass die moralität ins
spiel kommen aber kann zieht sehr
radikalen das sollte nicht von
glückseligkeit reden glückseligkeit hat
immer sowas graduelle sowas comparatives
glückseligkeit ist eigentlich gar kein
richtiger endzustand wenn glückseligkeit
nicht durch prinzipien der vernunft
geregelt ist
also glückseligkeit ist nicht das gute
sagt kann ist es nicht gegen aristoteles
die da die vernunft hat sie nicht
tauglich genug ist um den willen in
ansehung der gegenstände selben und der
befriedigung oder unser bedürfnisse die
sie zum teil selbst vervielfältigt
sicher zu leiten als zu welchen zwecken
eingepflanzten stick für gewisse geführt
haben würde
gleichwohl aber uns vernunft als
praktisches vermögen das ist als ein
solches dass ein schuss auf den willen
haben soll
die noch zugeteilt ist so muss die wahre
bestimmung derselben sei nein nicht etwa
in andere absicht als mittel seien an
sich selbst guten willen hervorzubringen
wozu schlechterdings von uns nötig war
woanders die natur über allen ans
auszahlung ihrer anlagen zweckmäßig zu
werke gegangen ist dieser wille darf
also zwar nicht das einzige und das
ganze habe muss doch das höchste gut und
zu allen übrigen selbst allem verlangen
nach glückseligkeit die bedingung sein
in welchem fall es sich mit der weisheit
der natur gar wohl vereinigen lässt wenn
man wahrnimmt dass die kultur der
vernunft die zuerst unbedingt
erforderlich ist die erreichung der
zweiten die jederzeit bedingt ist
nämlich der glückseligkeit wenigstens in
diesem leben auf mancherlei weise
einschränke
ja sie selbst unter nichts herr
abbringen können ohne dass die natur
darin unzweckmäßig verfahren weil die
vernunft die ihre höchste praktische
bestimmung in der gründung eines guten
willens erkennt bei erreichung dieser
absicht nur einer zufriedenheit nach
ihrer eigenen art nämlich aus der
erfüllung eines zwecks den wiederum nur
vernunft bestimmt fähig ist sollte
dieses auch mit manchem abbruch für den
zwecken der neigung geschieht verbunden
sein
das war zu langer satz
ich glaube der satz begann hier dieser
wille darf also halbe seite haben sie
trotzdem was verstand er bringt jetzt
hier nämlich interessanterweise den
begriff des höchstgebots in der mitte
sehen sie hier
was ist das höchste gut ist
als er sagt platzieren diese will
damit darf also zwar nicht das einzige
und das ganze muss doch das höchste gut
und zu allen übrigen selbst allem
verlangen nach glückseligkeit die
bedingung sein in welchem fall es sich
mit der weisheit der natur jawohl
vereinigen lässt wenn man wahrnimmt dass
die kultur der vernunft die zuerst an
und unbedingten absicht folie ist die
erreichung der zweiten die jederzeit
bedingt dass nämlich der glückseligkeit
wegs ist diesem leben auf mancherlei
weise einschränke dann selbst auf nichts
erbringen könne er spricht hier auch von
diesem leben
es könnte sein dass eben wir moralisch
sind der 5 geräuschen aber eben in
diesem leben keine glückseligkeit
arabischen grenze
ist damit nicht gesagt dennoch erkannt
sei der gute wille insofern das höchste
gut als er die bedingung der
glückseligkeit ist
also
der gute wille ist die bedingung der
glückseligkeit
also wir können eigentlich gar nicht
richtig glückselig werden wenn ich das
richtig verstehe wenn wir nicht einen
guten willen voraussetzen
das heißt aber nicht
dass der gute wille als solcher schon
zur glückseligkeit führt also ganz
schwieriges verhältnis die verhält sich
der gute wille zur glückseligkeit
oder wie verhält sich die vernunft zur
glückseligkeit die vernunft fordert in
sich dass mit der moralität mit dem
guten willen glückseligkeit geschehen
soll
aber sie kann es vielleicht nicht gleich
garantiert in dieser welt also weiter
lesen
um aber den begriff eines an sich selbst
hoch zu schätzen und ohne weitere
absicht guter willens der absolute wille
so wie er schon dem natürlichen gesunden
verstand beiwohnen und nicht sowohl
geleert als vielmehr nur aufgeklärt zu
werden bedarf diesen begriff der in der
schätzung des ganzen welt unsere
handlungen immer oben an steht und die
bedingung alles übrigen außen macht zu
entwickeln wollen wir den begriff der
pflicht für uns nehmen der den ideen
eines guten willens obzwar und der
gewissen subjektiven einschränkungen und
hindernissen enthält aber doch weit
gefehlt dass sie ihnen verstecken und
unkenntlich machen sollten
in filme durch absteckung heben und
desto heller hervorschauen lassen hier
am ende wieder mit hervor ich machen sie
mal auf die meta meta von aufklärung man
kann das ein aufklärer ist mir noch nie
aufgefallen was er hier sagt sagt hier
er muss nur aufgeklärt werden hat das
licht der vernunft bis dahin schon
enthalten wo jetzt kommt zum ersten mal
ergriff der pflicht also
das ist die ideologie die pflicht ethik
der vernünftig und der begriff die
pflicht enthält den guten willen und
sollen besonders deutlich hervor schein
lassen jetzt frage ich sie mal ganz
direkt inwiefern verträgt sich jetzt in
der gedanke von der pflicht mit dem
moralisch guten ist es nicht ihren
widerspruch
ist das wirklich so klar dass der
begriff ist der pflicht wir guten wir
herr vorschein lässt oder hätten sie
jetzt sich irgendwie so ein einwand dass
man sagt also ganz offensichtlich der
gute wille ist am besten dadurch
beschrieben dass man sagt das ist die
pflicht der weg gehorchen und das ist
ein guter wille oder moralität bedeutet
etwas pflicht zu tun
als uns sondern verpflichtet fühlen
würden sie sagen dass das der moralische
zustand ist
er spricht
solar ist ja auch nicht
ja
genau
wir folgen diesem jahr
ja
als zu essen sieht jetzt aber da sein
richtig man könnte damit sozusagen in
dem ich nach der pflicht oder aus
pflicht handle
man muss unterscheiden zwischen
pflichtgemäß dh ich handle weil ich
sonst strafe befürchten muss das ist
also pflicht gemäß nur als der
pflichtgemäßen oder aus pflicht weil ich
irgendwie das auch als gut anerkennen
können doch sozusagen selbst aus pflicht
handeln ist doch irgendwie noch fremd
bestimmen
das schreibt mir irgendwie jemand was
vor und irgendwie steht mir diese
vorschrift entgegen
diese blick schwebte über mir die
pflicht zwingt mich sie gebietet mir du
sollst das tun
bringen sie eine zehn gebote klickte du
solltest du sollst oder du sollst nicht
genau dasselbe könnte man auch verdenken
das hat doch eigentlich mit richtiger
moralität nicht zu tun weil es ich doch
immer irgendwie fremd bestimmt werde
ist das wirklich moral
das gibt es natürlich auch
weil sie
pflichtgemäß sagen die pflichtgemäße
genau also man muss offen sich das so
erklären dass aus pflicht handeln nicht
nur bedeutet etwas zu tun weil man es
tun muss
oder weil es wenn man es nicht täten zu
einer konsequenz führt die man nicht
haben möchte also man bestraft wird man
muss aus pflicht zu verstehen dass man
eigentlich den sinn der pflicht total
einzieht sind bei rechte überlegung
eigentlich sieht ja klar ist doch
sonnenklar
natürlich soll es tun weil ich es
eigentlich immer schon wollte ich will
es eigentlich in das will ich ja ich
weiss es zwar nicht immer aber
eigentlich recht besehen will ich es
eigentlich um ein vernünftiges ich wenn
ich nur vernünftig nachdenken möchte ich
es eigentlich freiwillig sozusagen also
in diese richtung geht jetzt diese
pflicht bei kann aber so ein bisschen
problematischer begriff weil man sagt
ich habe ja nur meine pflicht getan und
sie kennen alles würde man sagen ja das
ist nicht moralisches handeln hier
einfach eine pflicht zu folgen wer sagt
denn dass diese pflicht überhaupt
wirkliche pflicht ist dass dieses gebot
gut ist absolut gültig ist könnte doch
eine falsche pflicht sein
kant geht davon aus dass diese pflicht
die einzig wahre absolute pflicht ist
also wie das absolut das ist das gebot
was absolut gilt der kommen auch darauf
dass der kategorische imperativ das ist
die pflicht letztendlich 9,0 und jetzt
fängt er noch ein beispiel am schluss um
diesen unterschied zwischen aus pflicht
und pflichtgemäß klarer zu machen das
sagt ich übergehe hier alle handlungen
die schon als pflichtwidrig erkannt
werden ob sie gleich in dieser oder
jener absicht nützlich sein mögen denn
bei denen ist gar nicht einmal die frage
ob sie aus pflicht geschehen sein mögen
da sie dieser sogar wieder streiten
ich schätze auch die handlungen beiseite
die wirklich pflicht mäßig sind zu denen
alle menschen unmittelbar keine neigung
haben sie aber dennoch ausüben weil sie
durch eine andere neigung dazu getrieben
werden
und da lässt sich leicht unterscheiden
ob die pflicht mäßige handlung aus
pflicht- oder aus selbstsüchtigen
absicht geschehen sei
weil schwere ist dieser unterschied zu
bemerken wo die handlung pflicht mäßig
ist und das objekt noch über dem
unmittelbaren neigung zu ihr hat zum
beispiel ist es allerdings pflicht mäßig
dass der krämer seinen unerfahrenen
käufer zb kleines kind was bei ihm ist
das geld nicht abzählen kann nicht über
teure und wo viel verkehr ist tut dieses
auch der kluge kaufmann nicht so erhält
einen festgesetzten allgemeinen preis
für jedermann so dass ein kind ebenso
gut beim kauf als jeder andere wird also
jährlich bedient vom kaufmann allein das
ist lange nicht genug und deswegen zu
glauben der kaufmann habe aus pflicht
und grundsätzen der ehrlichkeit zu
verfahren
sein vorteil erfordert es dass er aber
über dem noch eine unmittelbare neigung
zu dem käufer haben sollte um gleichsam
aus liebe keinen von den anderen den
preisen vorzug zu geben lässt sich hier
nicht annehmen
also war die handlung weder aus pflicht
noch aus gummi die bauanleitung zu
endlosen eigennützige absicht geschehen
das ist jetzt ein bloß legales handeln
der kaufmann der das konkrete
wechselgeld heraus gibt obwohl er sagen
könne dem kind auch bewährt hat ist
teurer dann im motor dein vater haben
wir nicht genug geld mitgegeben person
oder das kostet das doppelte wenn der
jetzt den preis wirklich einhält dann
muss man immer fragen warum hat es getan
warum hat das getan hat es nur wegen der
pflichtgemäßen handelns getan also weil
er sagt ja gut wenn ich's halt nicht tue
und es fällt auf und die eltern des
kindes merken dass dann ist man ruf
ruiniert also eigentlich lieber
ordentlich
oder hat das deswegen getan weil er sagt
es ist unmoralisch ein kind zu betrügen
das verbietet mir die vernunft und weil
es die vernunft mir verbietet tue ich
nicht
hier muss man also immer nach den
motiven ausschau hab und gut wäre dann
ein solcher wille des kaufmanns wenn er
eben sagen würde ich soll meinen willen
prüfen nach dem kategorischen imperativ
nach vernunft gesetzen und wie diese
kalkulation dann hausfeld so handlich
aus sicht der kategorische imperativ
verbietet jemanden zu betrügen also tue
es nicht weil es der kategorische
imperativ eben nicht erlaubt
es sind jetzt mit der kritik der mit der
grundlegung zum ende siegt am ende
ich möchte jetzt das nächste nächsten
text nur sehr kurz ist nicht mehr jetzt
behandelten diesen letzten minuten
wir lesen in der nächsten sitzung hier
sagt kant jetzt anspricht kann es von
der dialektik der reinen vernunft in
bestimmung auf des begriffs vom höchsten
gut hier geht es um die frage nach dem
verhältnis von glückseligkeit und
moralität also folgt aus der moralität
die glückseligkeit oder im diesseits und
jenseits wie verhalten sich
glückseligkeit und moralität zu 200 das
ist die frage die wir im nächsten mal
klären wollen und dazu lesen wir diesen
sehr kurzen text aus der kritik der
praktischen bevor wir dann auf dem
nächsten denker übergehen was wer war
das aber ich glaube hegel war das glaube
ich hegels begriff des guten der kommt
dann schon im nächsten sitzungen und
sehen wir uns bis dann